hi there steve kaufman here again and i
want to follow up on my previous video
by the way i've come inside because the
sun is too bright outside
um and of course i have that picture in
behind me the
cafe painted by van gogh van gogh
in southern france al i think it was
cafe i can't remember anyway doesn't
matter
we talked about
whether people are vocabulary builders
or for vocabulary memorizers and i sort
of said that memorizers spend a lot of
time with anky decks or lists and try to
nail down vocabulary and that is a large
part of their language learning
vocabulary builders prefer to let the
vocabulary accumulate through
spending most of their time engaging
with interesting content now thank you
for responding
many people pointed out that they do a
bit of both and of course that's true
and that's also true in my case but the
issue is where do you spend most of your
time
and i also
agree that it depends on where we are in
the language as a beginner in a language
i will do more
sort of use of flashcards or the
activities that we have at link
because it's difficult to engage with
with even short content it's difficult
to follow the language we're not used to
the language whereas if we isolate
chunks of the languages like words and
phrases and review them in flashcards or
you know multiple choice activities such
as we have a link
then it's a form of engaging with the
language which we can cope with
sometimes better than actually dealing
with real life content then as i
progress in the language for example
where i now am in greek
uh where i'm sort of like a b1 you know
early intermediate i find that i like to
review my vocabulary uh as i turn a page
in link
not always i can choose you know we can
either just swipe and go to the next
page or we can hit the arrow which
brings up these activities but i like to
do them then hot like immediately upon
reading something or listening to
something i want to review the
vocabulary then as i progress in a
language i do less and less of that and
more and more of my activity is simply
reading and listening and particularly
listening and that gets me to the poll
that i want to do today
i think listening comprehension is the
most important skill it's the
fundamental skill if we understand well
what we hear when people speak to us if
we watch movies if we listen to the
radio we listen to audio books we listen
to stories if we understand well we are
on our way to being able to speak it
means that we can hear clearly what is
being said we have sufficient vocabulary
we have sufficient familiarity with the
language we have the ability to
understand what we hear that's a
fundamental skill so what and i spend
most of i would say that um i probably
spent 70 percent of my time listening
maybe 25 percent of my time reading and
then the rest is on
possibly reviewing words or
looking things up in a grammar book or
googling for grammar information so
listening is absolutely key
i get in i think on average an hour a
day
between being in the car working out
cleaning up around the house and so
forth i get in an hour a day that's
theoretically seven hours a week
what i would like to ask is how much
time do you all spend listening all
right and there'll be four sort of
options those people who get in seven
hours a week an hour a day seven hours a
week or more that's category one
category two is people who get in let's
say half that let's say three hours
three to seven hours a week of listening
and then the next category three is
those who get between one hour to three
hours a week of listening in and
category four is people who do less than
one hour a week of listening i would
like to see where you all fit in in
these four categories so that's the poll
uh
look forward to your answers
and thank you for listening and if you
enjoy these podcasts please subscribe
bye for now
[Music]
you